-Donald Trump is reportedly
planning to run
for president again to as a way
to protect himself
from a possible criminal
indictment
related to the attempted coup on
January 6th.
Meanwhile, the committee
investigating the coup
is planning to reveal
new details tomorrow
about what Trump
was doing that day
as the mob he incited
ransacked the Capitol
and tried to overturn
the election.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
At this point, the January 6th
committee hearing
have provided us with ample
evidence that Trump
and his gang of oddly shaped
goons committed multiple crimes.
I mean, that seemed
obvious on the day
the insurrection happened,
but now
we have a lot more detail.
It's kind of like how if you see
an employee at Dairy Queen
covered in ice cream with his
pants around his ankles.
You might think, "Is Chad
sticking his doink
in the soft serve machine?"
But then when you find a
detailed memo on his laptop
titled "Chad's Six Point Plan
for Dipping Doinks in the
Soft Serve Machine,"
you know for sure.
Even the Justice Department
seems taken aback
by all the new evidence the
committee has accumulated.
And as a result, the Feds are
now talking more openly
about Trump's behavior and
whether it constitutes a crime.
-According to
"The New York Times,"
the shocking testimony
of Cassidy Hutchinson
was so profound that it jolted
top Justice Department
officials into discussing
the topic
of Mr. Trump more directly,
at times in the presence of
Attorney General
Merrick Garland.
-Okay, I mean, I get that
Cassidy Hutchinson's
testimony was shocking,
but you're just now
getting around
to discussing Trump?
You're six years late.
Did you also just start watching
"Fleabag?"
Cheeky.
And Trump apparently
is quite afraid
of the various criminal
investigations
into his activities
on January 6th,
which is reportedly
one of the reasons why
he's likely to run again
and wants to announce soon.
He thinks being a candidate, and
specifically president again
will protect him
from going to jail.
-And now as the Justice
Department debates this,
he is telling people around him
he's going to run
for reelection as the ultimate
get-out-jail-free card.
-Many people around the
president who I spoke to
were talking about his concerns
about facing prosecution.
He's under investigations in all
sorts of different jurisdictions
in New York, in New York City,
with Department of Justice
in Georgia.
-He's under investigation
in New York, Washington,
Georgia, Peoria, Mayberry,
Twin Peaks,
Tatooine, Westeros, Xanadu.
He's even under investigation on
the planet from "Avatar"
for disguising himself as Na'vi
to steal some unobtanium.
[ Laughter ]
Incidentally, that's always what
he looked like
After he took
hydroxychloroquine.
"Rudy, I'm blue."
"Me too, boss.
I just find out
I married my cousin."
And that was today's unnecessary
Rudy reference.
-All the networks!
[ Laughter ]
-It's pretty amazing that when
Trump ran in 2016
his slogan was "lock her up,"
and in 2024 it's going to be
"vote for me
or I'm gonna go to jail."
I, for one, don't think
Trump needs another
get-out-of-jail-free card.
His whole life has been a
Pretty sure Trump could park
his golf cart
in the middle of the BQE during
rush hour
and the cops would just set up
orange cones around him.
Meanwhile, I park my car
in the fire lane for a minute
just to run into a CVS to see
if they have Clif Bar I like.
And when I get back, there are
nine different tickets plastered
on my window for stuff
like illegal parking,
blocking a fire lane, impending
an emergency vehicle
and one that just says "having
a big [bleep] mouth,
you smartass."
[ Laughter ]
So, Trump's plan, apparently,
is to run for president again
because he thinks that will
protect him from being indicated
by any of the various legal
entities investigating him.
And Trump knows he's
the one on the hot seat,
because to state the obvious,
none of this
would have happened without him.
All the various crimes
documented
by the committee
flow from him.
He's the kingpin.
Even if one of his cronies
broke the law
at his direction, that
implicates him, too.
I mean, it's not like these
random dudes just got together
and hatched a plan
for a coup without him.
It wasn't a surprise
birthday party.
There wasn't a magician there.
And if there was,
Trump would have tried
to rope the magician
in to the coup, too.
"Oh, and look, there's a quarter
behind your ear."
"That's fantastic.
Now make Mike Pence disappear."
Trump got this gang
of criminal goons
together himself,
and for the express purpose
of formulating a plan
to overturn the election
and stage a coup,
a plan which, at this point,
has been documented in
painstaking
detail by the committee.
-Throughout all these hearings,
they have been incredibly
consistent and rigorous about
how the ultimate culpability
for that dark day
and what led up to it
rests with Donald Trump.
And about how it was he that
plucked out these seemingly
random people, from a former
Federal Prosecutor
turned conspiracy
theory promoter, Sydney Powell,
to, well, the right-wing
pillow-selling dude,
to a random underling
in environmental law
at the Department of Justice,
Jeffrey Clark,
to another random right-wing
law professor who became
the author of the infamous coup
memo, John Eastman.
And he put this crew together to
try to end American democracy.
They didn't all know
each other beforehand.
It was Trump
that got them together.
It all flows from one man,
Donald Trump.
-This is the kind of
crew you'd put together
for "Ocean's Eleven"
if the goal was to get caught.
"We couldn't find an explosives
expert, but this guy
says he knows pillows."
"Hey, good news, every so often
one of my pillows does
spontaneously combust!"
Although I will say, contrary
to that clip,
I do feel like there
is a chance these four had
already met each other
in advance.
I mean, weirdos
find other weirdos.
Once normal people don't want
to spend time with you,
your friend options
are pretty limited.
I mean, remember, Sydney Powell
from her January 6th deposition
last week, repeating insane
conspiracy theories
And chugging diet Dr. Pepper?
-In the short period of time
you had with the president,
did he seem receptive
to the presentation
that you were making?
[ Laughter ]
-Regular people aren't going to
hang out with that lady.
Can you imagine Sydney Powell
just, like, going to a barbecue
at her neighbor's house,
talking about something
boring like re-seeding
your lawn?
"The reason your lawn is dead
is because Hugo Chavez
and the CIA teamed up
to turn off your sprinklers
using Dominion software
and Chinese satellites.
Now, if you'll excuse me,
I'm going to unhinge my jaw
and chug this entire can of
Diet Dr. Pepper
in one large gulp."
[ Laughter ]
That's when the couple hosting
the party goes inside,
gets into a fight
about whose fault it is
that she got invited
in the first place.
"I told you not to invite
your work friends!"
"I thought I could
set her up with Rudy!"
"Excuse me, Ms. Powell,
that's a lovely
soft drink you have there.
Any chance I'm related to you?
Don't answer, it's spicier
if I'm never sure."
[ Laughter ]
Sorry, guys, we did another one.
-America!
-And by the way,
that gang of weirdos Trump
brought together is still
trying to root out
nonexistent voter fraud,
even amid all the investigations
that are currently happening.
Like Mypillow CEO Mike Lindell
who said last week he's flying
in a plane full
of "cyber guys" to Arizona,
whatever the hell that means.
-I'm going to look
at the evidence.
On July 21st, I've got a
planeload of lawyers,
cyber guys, experts,
flying into Arizona.
We're flying a planeload
of lawyers down there, Brandon,
experts, cyber guys to testify.
-"Cyber guys" sounds like what
your dad calls "Transformers."
"You know, if you ever get tired
Of watching your cyber guys,
the grass out back
ain't getting any shorter."
That's right, Mike Lindell,
ol' Mike Lindell claims
he's flying a plane of
cyber guys down to Arizona
to prove voter fraud
or something.
Although, there's a good chance
Mike Lindell thinks
any commercial airline
is a plane full of cyber guys,
because all the passengers
are sitting in front of screens.
"It's a plane full of tech
wizards and cyber guys
who've got their own computers
built into the seats
in front of them, and these
computers are so advanced
you can pull up any
movie you want,
including "Gone Girl"
or the "Austin Powers" one
Or that one where
Leonardo DiCaprio
almost gets eaten by the bear!"
The straightforward, fundamental
question at the heart of these
Hearings and at the heart of our
politics at the moment
is whether we're
a nation of laws.
If Trump can simply
escape accountability
for a criminal plan
to overthrow the government
by running for president and
declaring himself untouchable,
then we no longer have a
functioning justice system.
As the January 6th committee has
documented in painstaking
detail, Trump and his cronies
have committed many crimes,
from inciting a riot
to doing this on camera.
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer
and other serious illness',
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe, get vaccinated,
we love you.